mich hat heute auch etwas bewegt und
zwar wieder nachrichten tag begangen es
begann mit einem buch das handelsblatt
berichtet die meldung dass vw der vw
chef herbert diess damit spielt 30.000
stellen zu streichen
in einer aufsichtsratssitzung im
september hat er dieses planspiel dieses
szenario an die wand geworfen die
aufsichtsräte reagierte empört auch
jetzt ist keinesfalls klage stellen
abgebaut werden es war ein
planungsszenario eine idee was ich mich
frage ist ist es im jahr 2021 eigentlich
normal mit provokation zu führen ist es
nicht unsozial szenarien an die wand zu
malen die eigentlich gerade noch gar
nicht wirklich ja da sind verwehrt ihr
immer wieder darauf hingewiesen dass der
weg zur elektromobilität keine stellen
kosten wird für mich ist dieses führen
mit provokation nicht gut es ist für
mich wenn ich es ehrlich sagen muss
passt scho asozial das zu tun und das
möchte ich gerne hier mit der runde
diskutieren ja lena also dieses beispiel
jetzt von vw ich kenne nichts
vergleichbares in der neueren ich habe
löschen oder us wirtschaftsgeschichte
meine was wir hier erleben ist im
prinzip ein mutwilliger selbst
auferlegten akt der deindustrialisierung
aus der industrie verschrottung und zwar
eines jener deutschen industrie der
vielleicht wie kein anderer zug zum
stolz dieses landes gilt meine frau war
eines der ganz großen wirtschaftswunder
stories leben geben die antwort jetzt
gar nicht ich muss dem fertigen auch
immer das hat natürlich das ist zwingend
was hier passiert ich meine das ist
jetzt einfach die folge davon wenn man
in dieser klima religion einfach
irgendwelchen falschen göttern hinterher
rennt der herr dies wurde noch
abgefeiert für seine klima umbaupläne
und das ist jetzt genau die quittung
klimapolitik diese diese klima wahnsinn
der kostet sehr viel der kostet 10
tausende von arbeitsstellen in
deutschland sind glaube ich etwa 800.000
arbeitsstellen in dieser
automobilindustrie trauen und da sage
ich einfach das ist die folge einer
falschen
ideologischen politik die vor allem von
der cdu bekämpft werden müsste hier in
deutschland und zwar das entschiedenste
gut dann bin ich jetzt schon
angesprochen quasi also sein gegner
sicher
in der tat ich glaube dass wir mit der
online electric strategie auf dauer
nicht richtig fahren werden weil eben
gerade was die verbrenner technologie
angeht wir viel know-how verlieren
werden bin ich voll bei ihnen und wir
brauchen das gerade für die großen und
schweren fahrzeuge für die müllwagen für
die krankenwagen für weiteres dass wir
eben umstellen auch auf e-mails die sind
vielleicht momentan noch nicht so
effektiv aber wir brauchen es
langfristig deswegen glaube ich auch
dass wir langfristig auch nicht nur auf
elektro setzen jahr für den
durchschnittlichen deutschen der 60
kilometer am tag fährt ist ein
elektroauto vielleicht auch eine
sinnvolle investition und das müssen wir
auch fördern aber es wird nicht für
jeden und es wird nicht für jede für
jeden ansatz der richtige weg sei
deswegen glaube ich dass wir schon noch
mal nach das aber passiert was was
meinen sie was ist das problem ist dass
das problem das elektroauto nicht
funktioniert oder sagen sie dass die
arbeitsplätze verschwinden wir haben
jetzt zwei themen also dass wenn wir den
elektromotor bauen weniger arbeit
entsteht ist ja klar aber was war das
problem an dieser ganzen geschichte ist
dass wir jedoch eine neue blauen
wirtschaft erleben weil diese entscheide
sind ja von der politik vorgespult die
geben ja eigentlich den konzernen vor
was sie machen sollen die medien juden
darum diese klimaretter hoch in den
konzernen ohne das ganze durch zu denken
aber den unterhalt sich auch sehr also
herr wird sie auch einer der manager die
sich schon sehr angenähert haben ich
würde sagen er kriegt ja allen masc auch
schon fast in den etwas wilder
ausgerückt aber es ist ja wirklich ist
es wie eine follower von allen masc und
heute was ich auch sehr sehr schlimm
fand die börse direkt reagiert auf
dieses die erklärung beim handelsblatt
die bürger praxis aber sie müssen warum
der heiß aber wir müssen aber der akku
einmal festtage und man sie haben gerade
gesagt der und der kann fahren und der
und ja nicht und so weiter sie geben
sich als beobachter aber sie sind teil
der partei die das ganze hier
verursachte
am ende ist es eine wirtschaftliche
entscheidung die sicherlich aufgrund der
flotten ziele aus europa auch durchaus
diese entscheidung getroffen hat also
wird flotten ziele entscheiden sie sich
die flotten zielen eher sagen eine
wirtschaftliche entscheidung der
automobilkonzerne zu entscheiden wie man
den umbau macht aber die sind getrieben
durch die flotten ziele aus der
europäischen union und dort sind sie
natürlich auch von deutschland und damit
eben auch von cdu-geführten regierung
vorangetrieben worden und deswegen ich
sage dieses thema und elektrik strategie
ist aus meiner sicht falsch orlen
electric ist nicht der richtige weg das
macht bei teilen sind bei kleinen
fahrzeugen bei fahrzeugen die wenig
strecke haben macht der elektromotor
wirklich sind aber bei großen und
schweren fahrzeugen oder langstrecken
fahrzeugen brauchen wir glaube ich auch
wasserstoff oder e mails und andere
modelle der tat auch noch eine frage und
zwar im wahlkampf hat ihr
kanzlerkandidat armin laschet ja immer
wieder gesagt wir müssen ökonomie und
ökologie miteinander versöhnen was das
genau heißt ob ich ehrlich gesagt nie
verstanden diese meldung kommt jetzt
nach der wahl muss man jetzt nicht
spätestens als cdu sagen der die
bekämpfung des klimawandels wird in
deutschland massiv arbeitsplätze kosten
also sie kann auch arbeitsplätze bringen
davon bin ich fest überzeugt wenn wir
eben neue technologien durchsetzen
am ende ist es so beim elektromotor wenn
wir wirklich nur auf elektromobilität
setzt nun auf batterie elektrobatterien
elektrische mobilität dann wird das
weniger leute brauchen weil ein
elektromotor braucht glaube ich so 80
teile und ein verbrenner motor 800 teile
das ist ein unterschied das kann sieht
jeder sofort dass das dann auch
wahrscheinlich weniger personen benötigt
aber es gibt ja andere technologien die
wir auch entwickeln können zukünftig
wird ja was das fahrzeug an geht
vielmehr auch auf konnektivität ist auf
konnektivität ankommen es wird um die
frage gehen wie wir vernetzt es fahren
hinbekommen und genau an dieser stelle
werden auch neue arbeitsplätze entstehen
von daher ist mir das zu einfach zu
sagen dass das jetzt arbeitsplätze
kosten wird ich glaube es gibt viel
potenzial auch gerade bei der frage der
zukünftigen fahrzeuge die wir
produzieren werden und die müssen wir
das müssen wir aus meiner sicht dringend
nutzen also dass chrome problem in
dieser ganzen geschichte besteht einfach
darin dass in einer normalen
marktwirtschaft und deutschland ist ja
eigentlich ein champion der
marktwirtschaft ist ja der markt der
konsument entscheidend und was haben wir
bei diesen elektroautos das ist ja eine
künstlich hochgepäppelt technologie
massiv verbilligt durch subventionen die
subventionen übrigen sind die tasche des
milliardärs elon musk fließen dann haben
sie fragen natürlich auch der re
verbilligten konsum also sie können so
eine auto günstiger kaufen wenn der
konsument die kosten wahrheit hätte bei
diesen elektroautos würden sie es ja gar
nicht kaufen und die politik steuert
eigentlich diese konzerne aber ich
kritisiere einen herrn dies weil dieser
herr dies ist wirklich auf diese klima
welle immer geritten er hat auch immer
behauptet judas geht locker das kostet
gar nichts doch das kostet was das
kostet zehntausende von arbeitsplätze
und niemand an diesem tisch weiß ob sich
die elektromobilität durchsetzen wird
obsiegen eine andere technologie bbt das
ist doch nicht unsere aufgabe wir sind
dabei mit dieser industrie auch die
marktwirtschaft auf dieser grünen
schlachtbank da das ist ja nicht abzug
von welcher zu weg zu befördern es ist
ja richtig die automobilindustrie hat
nie gesagt dass dieses problem geben
würde aber mal ehrlich was hätten sie
denn gemacht wählen sie in den
widerstand gegangen gegen die
europäischen
regierungen
ich glaube noch nicht politiker nicht
befehlen lassen was sich viele autos
produziert haben nach aber werden der
aktienkurs wenn sie herr köppel ceo von
vw werden also wir können jetzt hier
alle einmal schön auf handys drauf
dreschen ergibt ja auch wirklich vieles
von sich was irgendwie durchaus als
provokant zu werden ist aber der
aktienkurs ist kontinuierlich gestiegen
er hat um zwei 2018 übernommen der war
der aktienkurs bei 150 160 euro jetzt
ist er bei 109 aber philipp als anleger
bei vw recht zufrieden aber er habe ich
muss heute sagen wenn wir es nur von
aktien heute ist der aktienkurs übrigens
auch gestiegen als es hat ganz klar
gezeigt die börse reagiert auf
personalabbau besser als auf innovation
der börse stiegen da muss man aber auch
sagen was hinterlässt man bei den
mitarbeitern und am ende sind die
mitarbeiter also natürlich dann hat man
höheren börsenkurs aber zu welchem preis
langfristig gesehen glaube ich wird
diese diese meldung heute mehr geschadet
haben auch beim zusammenhalt im
unternehmen als jetzt dass der
börsenkurs ein bisschen nach oben
gegangen wir haben alles in der börse
abhängig machen und wir haben am ende
eine soziale marktwirtschaft das dürfen
wir nicht ganz vergessen nur
marktwirtschaftlich zu argumentieren ist
das eine aber wir haben am ende schon
auch eine soziale verantwortung für die
mitarbeiterinnen und mitarbeiter
und wir haben auch eine verantwortung
für die umwelt ich bin voll bei ihnen
dass wir technologieoffen rangehen
müssen ich glaube ich noch an einem
panel mit cem özdemir wo er sagte wer
für die technologieoffenheit plädiert
plädiert nur für die sicherung des
status quo und das ist falsch es ist
schlicht und einfach falsch weil wir am
ende wirklich alles brauchen wir müssen
die wir müssen der elektromobilität eine
chance gewähre elektrischen mobilität
eine chance geben müssen wasserstoff
eine chance geben müssen aber auch den
führerschein es gibt und das kann sich
ja entwickeln darüber aber diese
freiheit gibt es doch nicht sie haben es
gerade selbst gesagt das sind die
vorgaben aus brüssel und aus berlin und
der herr dies folgt dem ja nur
aktienkurs hin oder her er folgt dem
januar er ist ja er ist ja er ist ja
nicht der der die innovative die
innovationen vorantreibt sondern der den
politischen vorgaben folgt apple hat es
gesagt der planwirtschaft und dann sagen
sie
es ist der wettbewerb nein ist es nicht
wir haben in der hornberger hochlegen
sage ich ja deswegen sage ich ja auch
die order electric strategie die teile
ich nicht
[Musik]